bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78
politique alors faut-il ou non supprimer
les conseils généraux dans son discours
de politique générale c'est l'ambition
en tout cas affichée par Manuel Vals le
nouveau Premier ministre l'heure est aux
économies trop de mil000 feuilles
territoriales a-t-il dit actuellement il
existe les communes les
intercommunalités les conseils généraux
les conseils régionaux alors il n'y a
pas vraiment de précipitation si ça se
fait ce ne sera qu'à l'horizon 2021 mais
cela fait déjà beaucoup parler en tout
cas on va en parler avec vous Olivier
lebrin bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
général UMP président du groupe
majoritaire au sein du conseil général
des ivelines je rappelle juste que nous
avions invité un élu de gauche pour
débattre avec vous mais aucun n'était
disponible pour venir ce soir est-ce que
la suppression ou pas des conseils
généraux c'est un sujet qui porte à
discussion au sein du conseil général
des ivelines au sein dem C est-ce qu'on
en parle chez vous évidemment qu'on en
parle c'est c'est un sujet qui est
encore plus d'actualité bien évidemment
et on en parlait déjà il y a quelques
quelques mois voir quelques années parce
que c'est un sujet dont on parle depuis
30 ans c'est le le devenir des
conseillers généraux mais également de
des différentes strates du fameux
millefeuille on en parle le Conseil
Général fait partie des cibles en disant
peut-être que si on ENIT une couche ça
pourrait être le Conseil Général donc
après ça demande à être évident discuté
débattu sans précipitation 2021 ouais
c'est loin ouais et justement quelle est
votre position à vous est-ce qu'il y a
intérêt il y a un intérêt à conserver
les conseils généraux ou est-ce qu'il
faut repenser effectivement ce fameux
mil000feuille mil000feuille territorial
dont parle manuel Vals moi j'aimerais
d'abord qu'on qu'on définisse qu'on
parle des compétences avant de dire il
faut supprimer une strate il faut dire
quelles sont les compétences exercées
par la strate en question et quelles
sont celles qui pourraent être exercé au
mieux au plus proche de la population et
celle qu'on pourrait remettre à d'autres
endroits et là pour l'instant on entend
dire il faut les supprimer mais sans
savoir exactement comment
on va faire donc et vous savez les
compétences du Conseil général je sais
pas si vous voulez donner à vos
téléspectateurs bah on sait que c'est
des collège on sait que c'est le RSA on
sait que sont les routes départementales
notamment voilà par exemple il y a la
protection de l'enfance ça on on le sait
pas suffisamment les PMI sont dans le
les compétences du Conseil général il y
a le la la loocation adultes handicapé
donc la Maison Départementale du
handicap le les personnes âgées donc par
la pas donc il y a un nombre de de
compétences extrêmement important c'est
le Conseil Général le budget de
fonctionnement du conseil général c'est
1 milliard d'euros des yvelinesin c'est
un des des plus gros budgets de de
département de de France donc on doit
être le 5e département en terme de
budget donc c'est un budget extrêmement
important avec beaucoup de compétences
on a près près de 4000 salariés 4000
agents territoriaux qui travaillent au
Conseil Général donc je crois que on
peut débattre mais il faut se dire
surtout quel est le meilleur endroit
pour affecter les compétences qui sont
actuellement exercées par le le le
Conseil général mais vous êtes pas fermé
la discussion on n'est pas fermé la
discussion vous savez il y a une loi qui
était passée sous Nicolas Sarkozi qui
était la définition du Conseil
Territorial devait regrouper
effectivement le conseiller général le
conseiller régional dans un en un
conseiller territorial ça s'est pas
passé ça a été abrogé par le Sénat en
novembre 2012 oui alors c'est c'est
c'est passé ça été abrogé par le voà
quand même c'est c'est abrogé ensuite
mais c'était déjà un début de
rapprochement entre deux entités entre
deux collectivités et l'idée c'était de
dire on va diviser par deux le nombre de
d'élus conseiller généraux conseil
régionaux pour n'en faire plus qu'un
seul qui sera à la fois certainement en
mesure c'était pas annoncé comme ça au
départ mais qui sera en mesure ensuite
de faire la répartition des compétences
entre l'une et l'autre des entités et ce
qui fait qu'on on s'était dit
certainement à l'époque moins d'élus
donc peut-être moins de dépenses au
final je suis pas persuadé que ce soi
les élus qui créent les dépenses il y a
39 élus au conseil général des iblines
vous Co vous coûtez cher non bah il
semblerait qu'on coûte cher mais vous
savez la réforme c'était une question he
c'était pas une affirmation cé une
question mais en fait le la réforme donc
de la du Conseil Territorial a été
supprimé mais il y en a une autre qui
est arrivée avec la création des
conseils départementaux et au lieu de 39
élus on va en avoir 42 fa rappeler
qu'effectivement pour l'instant il y a
39 cantons aux prochaines élections
quantonales qui auront lieu en mars 2015
il y aura plus que 21 cantons donc on
réduit le nombre de cantons mais chaque
canton maintenant sera pas je sais pas
si administré le bon mot mais en tout
cas il y aura deux conseillers généraux
un homme une femme c'est exactement ça
ou l'avantage entre guillemets pour la
femme que je suis c'est que les femmes
vont plus rentrer au conseil général ça
c'est un autre un autre débat et du coup
il y aura de fait 42 Conseillers
généraux au lieu des 39 aujourd'hui
absolument et ça dans quasiment tous les
départements de France il y aura des des
conseillers génau en plus donc et les
conseillers régionaux resteront aussi
donc ça ne réduit pas au final le nombre
d'élus donc je ne sais pas si c'est le
si ce sont les élus qui coûtent cher ou
pas globalement quand même c'est
l'administration et les éventuels
doublons de compétences qui peuvent
exister selon les différentes strat
c'est là en fait qu'il fallait
travailler je pense alors faut-il ou pas
faire disparaître les conseils généraux
en tout cas c'est la question nous
sommes allés poser aux habitants de
Saint-Quentin Nivine on va écouter leur
réponse écoutez à partir du moment où il
faut faire des économies il faut que
tout le monde s'y mette et les conseils
généraux ils passeront aussi voilà je
pense que ce n'est pas une bonne idée
parce que les
conseillers généraux sont quand même
proches de notre vie et que nous avons
besoin
d'eux si c'est des économies utiles oui
mais si c'est pour
détruire faut voir hein je m'y entends
pas trop mais je crois que c'est pas une
très bonne idée il me semble aucune idée
la politique ne m'intéresse plus
monsieur dans le fond je suis pas contre
effectivement disons diminuer un peu
toutes ces échelons intermédiaires
entre le pouvoir et puis les mairies en
passant par les Conseils Régionaux
généraux et cetera conseill européen
donc dans le fond je suis pas contre
pour faire des
économies on n plus à la à l'air de
Napoléon et que qu'il ait des régions
que une région soit capable
d'administrer la un territoire grand
comme trois ou quatre départements ça me
paraît tout à fait normal al on n plus à
l'heure de Napoléon à l'URE de Napoléon
il a raison le monsieur et d'autres
parlent de d'économie nécessaire
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de leur
répondre à ces habitants ah ben je vois
que c'est partagé en tout cas y a
beaucoup oui il s'est partagé il y a
quand même beaucoup de bon sens c'est
vrai il y a beaucoup de bon sens et je
pense que c'est ça en fait qui doit
piloter l'action du gouvernement des
décideurs en l'occurrence c'est le bon
sens le pragmatisme et je le disais tout
à l'heure définissons les compétences
qui et où elles doivent aller si c'est
au niveau du conseil régional qu'ell
doivent se positionner pourquoi pas si
c'est sur communité pourquoi pas mais
l'échelon de la proximité une une
interview V le disait c'est il faut la
proximité est fondamentale et je crois
qu'elle elle est important parce que le
l'élu il est élu sur un territoire et le
fait d'être élu sur un territoire donne
aussi une une obligation à l'élu d'être
prés sur son territoire regardez les
conseils régionaux on est l des listes
on ne voit quasiment jamais les conseils
régionaux sur le sur le territoire les
conseils générraau ils sont en contact
direct avec les Mair ils sont dans un
canton ils ont entre une et et 30 ou 40
communes à à s'occuper donc là il y a un
vrai lien entre entre les deux donc ce
pointl est quelque chose de fondamental
la proximité et la proximité c'est à mon
sens plus d'efficacité mais est-ce que
la proximité elle va pas aussi venir de
par des intercommunalités puisque
aujourd'hui les communes sont regroupées
en inter communalité dans quelques
années elles devront même être des
grandes intercommunalités de 250000
habitants alors qu qu'elle va être la
place d'un d'un conseiller général qui
va gérer même j'allais dire un petit
canton plus petit que 250000 habitants
alors le les intercommunalités ont
vocationec à grandir puisque c'est le
l'objectif depuis pratiquement
maintenant une une quinzaine d'années
c'est de de créer des intercommunalités
maintenant on définit leur taille entre
200 250 300000 habitants pourquoi pas
mais je pense que il est nécessaire
aussi qu'il y ait une politique qui se
fasse au niveau un petit peu plus lar
lge pour essayer de de d'harmoniser un
petit peu les pratiques on va avoir des
intercommunalités qui vont être riches
d'autres qui vont être avec des des
ressources relativement faibles des
intercommunautés urbaines des
intercommunautés rurales elles ne
pourront pas toutes avoir les mêmes
types de compétences et c'est ça aussi
la difficulté qu'on a en France c'est
que on définit souvent une même
architecture pour l'ensemble de la
France alors que les territoires sont
différents ne serce que dans les
ivelines dans les ivelines on a des
cantons ruraux on a des cantons très
urbains donc fait les problématiques ne
sont pas les mêmes donc c'est là aussi
qu'il faut certainement avoir un petit
peu plus de d'audace certainement pour
essayer de de de trouver un autre un
autre schéma de fonctionnement parce
qu'il ne faut surtout pas abandonner les
territoires ruraux notre président du
conseil général Pierre béer nous
d'ailleurs a la création d'une agence
rurale c'est pas le terme exact mais une
agence rurale qui va se créer d'ailleurs
une agence d'aide aux communes rurales
parce que c'est clair que elles ont
aussi besoin d'une d'une aide importante
le Conseil Général al l'heure actuelle
aide beaucoup les collectivités les les
maies notamment à définir des des
équipements des des éléments structurant
pour leur territoire des gymnases des
écoles si le Conseil Général disparaît
il FAA bien que quelqu'un aide aide à le
faire sinon en fait c'est un grand pan
de d'aide financière qui va disparaître
au profit de je ne sais qui d'ailleurs
donc là c'est c'est un vrai sujet au
profit de je ne c'est qui on va
peut-être écouter maintenant André
Sylvestre c'est le président des élus du
groupe de gauche au Conseil général
desines et lui il a peut-être il a sa
petite petite petite idée pardon sur les
nouvelles compétences que pourrait avoir
le prochain conseil général romagier on
écoute on a oublié peut-être que il y a
quelques années déjà le gouvernement
c'était pas le gouvernement de gauche
avait envisagé la suppparation des
départements puisqu'il y avait la fusion
avec les les régions par les conseillers
territoriaux donc aujourd'hui ça nous
paraît un petit peu un petit peu
provocateur de dire que on veut que
c'est la gauche qui veut créer les
départements il y a longtemps que que
cela est arrivé je pense peut-être que
s'il y a une redéfinition des des
compétences entre les régions et une
autre structure qui remplacerait les
département exemple que les régionsnent
en charge les collèges les lycées et
cetera et que l'on donne aux
intercommunalités toute la partie
sociale c'est vrai que le département
n'a plus de raison d'exister encore faut
il faut il faut s'attaquer au à une
réforme en profondeur et non pas
quelques réformettes comme on a
l'habitude de faire alors on a commencé
par une petite pique he d'André
Sylvestre à l'encontre des élus de
droite ensuite quand il parle
effectivement peut-être de donner des
compétences au conseil régional comme
les collèges et puis redéfinir des
compétences aussi pour les
intercommunalités c'est un peu ce que
vous dites en fait c'est un peu votre
discours revoir les compétences et donc
il y aurait forcément une strate enent
trop oui clairement vous savez il y a
peut-être une strate vous êt assez
d'accord avec lui non enfin je suis je
suis d'accord sur le fait qu'il y a
certainement une clarification des
compétences à avir et la question du
millefeuille je reviens un petit peu
dessus parce que on dit dans l'esprit
général de la population en tout cas il
y a le milfeuille il y a trop il y a
trop de couches en l'occurrence on est
en train d'en créer une de plus c'est le
gouvernement a créé également les
métropoles n'oublions pas ça c'est la
métropole qui est c'est une de plus qui
se trouve donc c'est Paris plus les les
départements la petite couronne donc 6
millions et demi d'habitants sur une
région qui on comporte 11 11 et demi
donc c'est c'est un un mastodonte et à
côté on va avoir des départements qui
vont se retrouver un petit peu isolés et
on se retrouverait juste avec des
intercunalités de 200000 habitants par
rapport à une métropole de 6 millions et
demi donc une sorte de disproportion non
négligeable donc ça c'est un point
important faut pas faire disparaître
certaines strates si on en crée de de
nouvelles donc moi j'entends simplement
ce qu'a dit le Premier ministre qui nous
dit il faut supprimer les départements à
l'hon 2021 mais surtout en fait il faut
savoir comment on fait qui on quelle
compéten
ne ner cherch avant tout l'efficacité
c'est ça que je dis aprèsett le les les
dépenses sociales auès auprès des
inommunalités je dire pourquoi pas mais
ça c'est un vrai vrai sujet parce que il
faut pas non plus qu'il y ait des
intercominalités à plusieurs vitesses et
c'est le risque entre le rural et
l'urbain c'est un vrai risque qui peut
qui peut se est-ce que ça dire que le
Conseil Général des va déposer un pas un
projet mais en tout cas des propositions
sur cette en cas de de d'accord sur la
suppression du conseil général est-ce
qu'il y a possibilité de déposer des
propositions alors chaque fois qu'il y a
eu des choses de genre là le Conseil
général desésiveline a fait des
propositions parce que sur le
redécoupage des cantons il y avait des
propositions de contre redécoupage des
cantons absolument et notamment en fait
lorsqu'on a entendu parler de la
métropole que la métropole a été initiée
et créée par une loi fin 2013 on a
proposé aussi que le Conseil Général des
ivelines se fusionne avec le Conseil
Général d' valdoise et des hautes scènes
là aussi pour dire on a aussi on a notre
mot à dire et on ne veut pas être perdu
dans le à à l'ouest de la métropole et
être une petite entité qui qui sera trop
petite par rapport la métropole donc ça
c'est on fera des propositions de de
toute façon parce que nous ce qu'on
cherche avant tout c'est c'est de nous
dire l'aide qu'on apporte à la
population et aux collectivités locales
du territoire on on tient absolument à
ce que cette aide soit euh en tout cas
pérénisée ou qu'elle aille bien au bon
au bon bénéficiire et c'est ça le sujet
nous ce qui compte avant tout ce sont
nos communes et les Vinois merci pas
autre chose merciiv d'être venu sur
place 7 politique nous apporter votre
éclairage sur une évolution du conseil
général vous dites évolution possible en
tout cas c'est on n'est pas fermé à une
évolution il y aura des
contrepropositions qui seront faites par
les ivlines ça c'est sûr ah B ça sans
doute merci beaucoup bonne soirée
merci